everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 294 of the ask gary vee
show this an exciting episode for me as
you can see I'm perched outside my
office I have a small group of friends
here we did a really fun barter party
for the clouds and dirt so I want to
first let's clap it up for each other
really nice crew here I know we're live
on Facebook as well we're gonna probably
take most of the questions from here and
I have two wonderful guests here and
I'll explain in a minute why one reason
is I'm very excited about doing their
event which will bring a little bit of
awareness to but the gentleman dear to
them I write with the help of the
gentlemen here to my left if if if I
could think about how many individuals
are out there if if one looks back in 20
or 30 years and says Wow crush it was a
book that was written about social media
that really kind of nailed it
and created a blueprint that I then
followed and created companies followed
myself if there's people outside of me
who've executed and many of you are in
the process of doing that and many of
you watching even more so but if if you
asked me in 20 years and definitely
today to speak to the individual or
individuals that best executed against
the thesis it's very difficult for me to
think of a name better and and doing it
longer and more importantly
authentically from reading actually
crush it to changing their lives to then
jumping early on platforms and executing
them building around it it's very
difficult for me to think of somebody
who's done it better than shonduras and
so I'm very happy that it's here so
let's clap it up for him on that
and so for the vaynernation that's
watching some of the people in here that
may not know who you are
why don't you two beautiful men
introduce yourselves I gave you a little
context why don't you jump on it so I'm
a professional wrestler going by the
name of nice guy so I started out on
social media I did the snapchat thing I
was one of the first snapchat pioneers
did the very first brand deal with
snapchat kept pushing the limits going
from there built an entire community
built the ecosystem for what was
snapchat brand deals and how we worked
with brands and partnerships a lot of
that was through Gary from snapchat I
learned I wanted to diversify get
something more scalable went over to
YouTube that's seen more long-term but
it still didn't have the scalability
that I wanted to so I continued going
now we have a full talent management
agency we're really big into eSports
we've got space station gaming and
continue to build other businesses
outside of just social media we have a
conference coming next month that Gary's
gonna be speaker at holidays the guy
here who helped me all of it yeah so vid
summit is the conference at referencing
to in LA
October 9th through the 12th Gary speaks
on the 10th so if you're gonna come come
the 10th so a little about myself
traditional startup guy that raised
money before with companies had made
every effort to get in front of this guy
would come to these types of events try
to bump rub shoulders in that you know
when he'd speak and now on stage with
him which is amazing so about a year two
years ago started with just Shaun hadn't
I literally know people made money on
YouTube he didn't know any money deep I
was when he came work for me Mike I
let's dig into YouTube so like you know
PewDiePie is like wait who oh my god I
got a lot of work today no Casey was
like really really oblivious to kind of
the scene came on with Sean from like a
business perspective not as much like I
wanna get famous I want to get numbers
and from that business perspective I had
one goal which was make money and scale
and so he jumped in with Sean started
making money and scaling which was
amazing and then from there found that
there was so much like over flow off of
Sean and so we started picking up one of
those overflows was from Gary
so Gary would kick some stuff kind of
unique opportunities and invitations and
kind of connections and then we took and
started saying wait what if we worked
with other influencers
and so we started working with other
influencers and from there we built a
talent management called Space Station
integrations now we work with some of
the biggest talent on YouTube so Sean
started you don't talk to me about the
jewelry company after you read crush it
I was gonna keep that one a secret bring
it bring it bring it cuz I think it's
super important because I think for a
lot of people that are watching and for
even a bunch of us in this room like I
started off as a wine retailer I think
the thing that most people struggling
when I look around this room like all of
us have one two three more chapters in
us I think people struggle with
understanding how deep the innovation
and disruption that the internet is
actually causing I think that a lot of
people see the final result but they
don't understand the steps that take
they're so off of bleeding crush yet
what were you doing and then what they
do next so I was in college because I
didn't know what I want to do with my
life but I wanna do something really
cool right and my teacher had me read
crush it by this guy named Gary Vee all
right let's read this thing read it I
was like oh dang this is incredible I
need to figure this stuff out so I
started running my own business it was a
skateboard snowboard shop coolest part
about owning a skateboard snowboard shop
you literally just chill and watch
snowboard videos all day is dope we're
smart about owning a snowboard shop you
literally just chill watch videos all
day you don't sell anything it's not
dope so crush it helped me realize
there's so much more out there there's
different platforms where you can share
message sell a product give a service
whatever and that's when I want to try
something new so I wanted to figure out
the internet internet was killing myself
because everyone bought their stuff
online free returns everything else so I
wanted to figure out how can I sell
skateboard snowboards online after being
cursed I was like wait this isn't the
best idea this is working harder not
necessarily smarter I love snowboards
but doesn't mean I need to sell them so
I really put together a business plan of
what would be the most effective way to
start my first online business and I
came to the conclusion of jewelry it was
small it was lightweight there was a
huge market for it and the platform I
chose to build my business on was
Facebook at the time like kind of the
very first social media platform that
really hit hard
I ran the entire jewelry boot jewelry
boutique under my wife's name so that
was a little creepy like skater kid
running a jewelry boutique out of the
back of the shop so it was all under her
name you know rainy day all right lady
he's like what movie gonna watch day and
be like The Notebook gonna be already
seen it like it got weird guys but it
taught me a lot about building a
business and the power of social media
so from there I was like oh this is the
real dill scaled that one year was able
to sell it had actual money in my
pockets paid off student loans and
started what would be my next business
which was in social media that's where I
identified snapchat took it from there
so from reading Gary's book crush it to
executing on that finding success
digging deeper and then I was you know I
was just bragging I'm the very first
quote in crushing it so you know only
one person has the first quoting
crushing semi limited real estate Sean
yeah so how did you get to Sean like so
you're a startup kid you're playing in
that world what how'd you find Sean what
what what played out yeah so a little
background Sean and I like Sean Duras
the name was from a mission that we went
to in Honduras so he got home they
called him Sean from Honduras Honduras
so it's kind of the history of the name
so we knew each other there just a
little bit
nothing crazy though when I got back I
was running my startup and was super
deep and Sean was coming into town for a
brand deal in Mesa Arizona he's like hey
can I stay with you I don't wanna stay
at this hotel is like sure so he slept
on the floor of my house we stayed up
all night talking [ __ ] up so for the
plan was to sleep on the floor
they say depth oh is that how you rolled
back then like you wouldn't want to go
to hotels you just like oh yeah
everything's networking connections old
friends I saw he was killing it he had
his own startup business that crashed
and I was like dude I want to learn from
you like I'm new in the snapchat thing
you did your thing like let's hang out
Jim spent the whole night talking next
thing you know I'm like dude I'm getting
way deep into public speaking I was kind
of trying to be Gary's understudy at the
time and if Gary didn't do a deal I
would do a deal we spoke at a couple
events together and I was like dude i
wanna crush public speaking his previous
business was an app that turn your phone
into a microphone so anyone out there
you know just pulls up their phone ask
the questions super simple I was like
you know the speaking world helped me do
this and he helped me do it he helped me
get my first speaking gig got me a TED
talk provided all this value no payment
and I was like dude this guy hustles how
do I get him on my team so was like yo
what would it take you to move you out
you and your family out to Utah real
real quick for everybody watching and
listening on the podcast before we
started this episode
with the group of 17 25 people that are
here I said look before you leave make
sure you say hello cuz I've been
watching them for the last hour and a
lot of people haven't said hello to each
other I you know I love when you you
know Instagram is a limiting platform
for me which is why the most
motivational version of myself is on
that platform with one-minute video
being the length and when pictures and
quotes there's only one part of what I
can show there but there's a quote that
I put on Instagram it just says you know
people are the ROI right and you know
you can only do so much to explain a
post even with long copy and I do that
of what that purpose is but it's
interesting to me in what I tried to
pressure this groom to do over the next
two or three hours is exactly what you
did which is people or the ROI and I
think what's super fascinating to me as
we become more and more digital the
sleeping over somebody's house the
random dinner meetups events like this
and anything everybody in here or
watching or listening right now can do
to put them in a place with like-minded
people is like disproportionally the
right thing to do yeah you guys want to
know a cheat code for that I've been
using this for years and it works yeah I
already use it on some of you guys out
here so don't get weird it out but I go
around talk to everyone I can have the
most meaningful five-minute conversation
where I'm listening I'm not on my phone
I figure out exactly who you are learn
from you become friends and then I go oh
dang is there food around here I've been
looking for some food dude I mean you'll
find some food I'll catch you later then
I walk just down turnt start talking to
someone else five minutes you know their
food around here I'm trying to get some
food and then that way you don't get
caught in the thirty I want to celebrate
for all the people listening watching in
the future when you pull the food card
that means you're ready to move on from
them yeah exactly cool just want to make
sure all of you but I want to talk to
you for 30 minutes I want to talk to
everyone here for five minutes and to
end that conversation yo is there food
are those drinks I'm gonna go check
those out but you never actually get
food you just keep hopping around and
look guys because I think for a lot of
people that are listening or watching I
think not at everybody's extroverted and
can do that right you hear that with his
energy and sigh cool that works for him
I think it's really interesting to learn
skills or like break your habits to me
it's one thing to have that ability to
work a room for real there's a whole
nother thing that I'm most fascinated by
which is what's happening here right now
physically which is you're ready here
it's you know it's one thing to like
have that ability if you're actually
there and to me the whole like minded
you know events like to me going to a
huge networking thing like business
networking sucks because it's so not
that it sucks it's not as conducive to
what I'm trying to push everybody to do
because the concept is very broad
whereas if you go to an event that is
around an individual or a very long tail
event like Super Mario Brothers - like
if you go to a Super Mario Brothers to
meet up everybody's there for a [ __ ]
Super Mario Brothers - like you should
be able to have a lot of conversations
because you're so long tail so a
business event versus a cryptocurrency
meet up around one single currency
that's nine weeks old and there's 15
people there if you're if you find
yourself introverted I can't tell you
enough how important it is to find the
long tail of your interests because it's
gonna make you feel more comfortable
because the context is so deep though
the group might be smaller but the
ability for you to interact becomes
greater so just something to think about
or everyone loves food just because
their food here and start talking to him
fair enough so how do you find him so he
found you
yes show to the house and I was you at a
slumber party running scaling this
business and I remember we wrote down on
this piece of paper to like 4:00 in the
morning like here's the verticals of my
business I'm focused on for shauna with
snapchat YouTube and they had this
vertical that was speaking he's like
guys don't at the time or effort or team
like I just can't pull it off and at
this time it was just him in an editor
right and they were doing all this
YouTube and snapchat stuff and so I was
running a company at the time in the
event world and I said let me just jump
in so Alex who's in the back here was a
buddy at the time and he started kind of
helping me navigate that world a little
bit and so we got Sean at EDX we spoke
three times right after Gary so Gary you
can we would go to the event and say hey
we might warm them up and then I was
like you know with Darien so he would
speak right to Gary Oh while I'm still
running my own company here I just added
value so when I came down to got rid
sold a start-up and we were moving on
first guy Sean calls is like yo dude
congrats like come be on my team
I'd already had 12 months of connection
hustle value and so it's a really easy
transition we knew how to work with each
other we knew how to do it and I never
made a dollar off of him so for me
especially having everybody here where I
want to transition into his heavy Q&A
and I'll tell you why I think what I'm
setting up here what my personal kind of
mission is is I'm starting to realize
especially over the last week or two
I've been thinking quite a bit about
this which is the maturity of building
infrastructure around a personal brand
is pretty remarkable
right like if I wasn't running Boehner
full-time I I started realizing my god I
probably have 55 full-time people in
garyvee Inc and like that means that in
15 to 20 years you know the model of
like you know it's happened right
whether it's an Oprah or you know so
many other things that about Newman
right you know Paul Newman like the
amount and you can go on and up Jordan
and the branch or like I think the long
tail of human Inc is far greater than
people realize I think these that we are
in the you know national anthem of an
18-inning game of like what a business
looks like I think we've all realized
especially over the last decade oh crap
as a personal brand you can speak you
write books there you can get you can be
a youtuber and get tons of pre-roll ads
I don't think people realize the
maturity of how far this goes when you
go into merch
ni P and just disproportionately I think
over the next four to five decades we
will see hundred five hundred four
billion dollar companies built around a
human
we've seen a couple of being able to do
that in a traditional landscape but way
more important to everybody watching and
everybody here how about a hundred
thousand so for me what's super
interesting to me is how many people in
America let's just stick with America
would rip their arm off to make a
hundred thousand dollars a year a lot or
more importantly how many people make a
hundred twenty seven thousand a year
being something that they hate and how
much they would love to make a hundred
thousand a year being a baker or a
candle maker or like a shoe expert or
the foremost expert on Space Jam right
and so
to me I what I'd like to do knowing a
lot of this audience so I'm thrilled set
set that we want to take questions from
Facebook but specifically here let's
open it up
who's got a question around personal
brand or that thematic if you're in here
now hands
let's move the mics who's got him all
right name and question my name is Brock
Johnson so my question is at what point
do you so at a certain point you get one
to two people to help you yes and at a
certain point it gets to where it scales
and then it's like you have to hand it
off from being you in that point like
how do you transition from zero to one
and then that one to six and beyond of
that building the infrastructure of
human Inc like you're talking about oh I
got this cuz I did it I was just me just
shonduras and I couldn't film all my
videos and be talking and running a new
company and doing all this stuff so I
connected him with everyone I knew
I gave him access to everything I had
access to and then I let go of creative
control because that's what you have to
do if I want him to send an email the
way I want to send it it's not going to
work I teach him what my voices but then
I give him full creative control and
I'll tell you he one of my businesses he
runs it more than I do he knows more
about it than I do and he's scaled it
bigger than I ever thought it would go
because I gave him full control and then
took away my crazy my creative control I
guess thoughts yeah I think you know
there's this certain level of control
but I think the other part is like who
is on that team right
finding the right culture fit like Shawn
and I are just best friends from we have
the same first name yeah and like there
it is folks I think that hire people
with your first name and away go it's
all billions after that so I think it's
it's really comes down to rocks gonna be
hard you've made good luck
you know you've met a lot of Gary's team
and a lot of them have the same vision
and culture and like not just ingrained
in them from Gary but like from birth
right and just some of those assets you
have to find and have and so I would say
as far as not from 1to you know that but
finding that one I think that one really
has to be
ingrain and what you are and the culture
you have because that one's gonna get -
and then that twos gonna get four and
four six eight and on and on and on
Gary's prove it with nine hundred but
that first couple a really really
important for me there's a couple things
right so something interesting has been
happening in my team Dirac and I were
you might have saw if you're following
closely I was garage saleing this
Saturday and Lou who's not here who's
his name is little loot to me because
I've known him since he was six
his dad was my friend in the wine
business I've literally known him since
that was six he's worked here since he
was 18 he didn't go to college like he's
like been here for five six years he's
like one of my Jets friends so he's like
a real friend and I just know him
extremely well like he's like one of the
kind of like people I really know so he
was with us if you were hardcore
watching he was the one holding up the
teddy bear in the background this
weekend when I found the twenty dollar
angry bear anyway at the rock are you
here okay
I think this is right I think this is
right I think Lou
so this Saturday is this Wrightson and
you know where I'm going I was in the
car in between garage saleing posting on
Instagram like the post was in we have a
system like a text chain a system we
have a [ __ ] text chain where there's
where there's a bunch of creative that
we work on together there's a lot of
team here and I picked the one I liked
and I started writing the copy and
little Lou who I've known for 20 years
who's worked here for the last six who's
like always around is like sitting in
the back cuz he rocks in the front seat
and he goes what are you doing and I go
I'm posted you know I thought he meant
why am I wasting a few minutes cuz we
have to get quickly get to the next
garage sale because we don't somebody
take some good [ __ ] I was like oh I'm
just gonna quickly post this instant
like I'll be you know I got a post this
he goes you post your own Instagram so
so the answer is yes and I think I write
all the copy and I think people realize
how bad my grammar is so I think they've
understand that but I still don't think
they believe it or they think somebody
does it I think the biggest thing that I
think about when scaling is what do you
keep and what
do you let go and that has to be
individual the way you scale is by
realizing five people doing an 80 of
your hundred is better than just you
doing a hundred and so first and
foremost it starts with ambition so for
example a lot of people say [ __ ] like oh
don't look at Gary Vee he has 20 [ __ ]
people like that's why you you know but
but what they don't realize is first of
all and Andy I'm trying to look for you
and that's about me but like the reality
is like in its truth and a lot of the
teams here in its truth we could be
remarkably efficient doing what we're
doing with six or seven the reason I
have twenty is I'm training a lot of
them to infiltrate the overall
organization in the long term I have 20
because I want you know cuz babban right
now is working has been working if you
haven't noticed he hasn't been around in
the content he's working with Boehner
Talent one of our divisions and 137 p.m.
is something I have enormous ambition
for and whether it's an an orcid or
there's so many people Jake there's so
many people on the team here that I know
can go and dominate there but I'd like
them to get incubated for six months to
a year or two and really [ __ ] know it
so my ambition is to buy the New York
Jets and so creating scale and being
inefficient with xx and we are plenty
[ __ ] inefficient with the amount of
people we have and that's why
everybody's smiling
it still ry positive because I'm gonna
scale them to the you know to the 900 I
think you need to know what your
ambition is first and foremost and then
I think you need to hold on to what you
value the most I on Instagram and
Twitter every single one of those posts
or me and I need it to be me and I have
to have it be me and like it means a lot
to me that it's me and that's what means
something to me and so you know that's
just the way it is so I think you need
to think about what you want to be doing
with your time and what you value and
then you start building a team around
you that has complimentary skills to the
things and I go one of two ways either
they're very like you and for me too
what you mentioned I saw people shaking
their heads to me where my team has to
be very like me is they have to be nice
not super complicated
I'm completely suffocated in negativity
thus if I'm the [ __ ] engine I don't
care if somebody's the greatest growth
hacker or can [ __ ] design
his [ __ ] Pablo Picasso with Pablo
Picasso is a [ __ ] dick he's out um
that's what has to be like me everything
else has to be not like me like you have
to be able to read an email you know
like and many other things right and so
you know I think that you have to ego is
what holds back people from growing
right they like the feeling in companies
and personal brains are tough right
because it's you so like I'm not
comfortable with somebody writing on my
behalf
like I have to say everything I say like
every piece of content is transcription
from my words like people like like I
always read the reviews they're like oh
my god this book sounds just like you
Gary Vee I'm like right like it's
literally like the ghostwriter is
literally just making a grammar its
transcriptions so I think that's we have
to think about okay so I I don't have to
feel guilty about my slack channels just
being really unorganized so it's just
you really focus on speed and people
like you yeah I mean to me to me like
you need to be you like everybody's
gonna always win most if they lean in
more to what they are instead of trying
to do something that they see somebody
else doing well and be ideological about
it in art and sports we've accepted that
we're not LeBron or Beyonce right for
some reason and entrepreneurship we have
this false feeling that we can be we
have not layered the talent card into
the entrepreneurs you'll creative land
to the level that I think we need to
like everybody just thinks that they're
gonna make a million dollar business
that it's so easy in a way that we don't
with putting out a rap album or playing
basketball and and that's a day of
reckoning that needs to happen in the
space to help everybody for me I'm only
comfortable in chaos like there's a
report card hanging there in my office
you know for a couple reasons one I just
think it's hilarious but more
importantly you know I'm not going to be
organized that's not what I get paid to
do that's not
Who I am I feel no bad about that
whatsoever I want to find people that
are comfortable in her organization and
I'll tell you Andy who's my right hand
and the guy I've watched him not get
less organized I've watched him and
everybody else on my team prioritized
better because they they start off more
organized and then I systematically in
osmosis take out of them to not focus on
dumb [ __ ] even though they're the one in
charge of the more and they have to care
more than I do but no I don't think you
beat your I mean beating yourself up
around your DNA is such a negative
exercise what you need to do is figure
out what you naturally do best and
quadruple down on that and then build
infrastructure around it I genuinely
believe that the end that's why that's
why I love QA that's why that's why I
struggle with some of the stuff I put
out because I hate that I can't have
full context - I love QA I need the
context the best advice I give her to
people I know the best questions so you
got your personal brand is up my name is
Allen Berube
I'm from Saco Maine and I was wondering
about your branding your name
so have you did you just say hey I'm
gonna brand my name was there another
business idea that you thought maybe it
was gonna be the brand instead cuz you
know it really puts a lot of emphasis on
you and when your brand your name you
just kind of stuck with that right you
can't change it can't change it as in to
me I love the name because I actually
think it gives you disproportion of
flexibility to do anything as a human if
you go from wine guy to social media guy
to like whatever you want to do next I
think it gives you that flexibility
whereas if you're like the photo expert
and then you want to write you're like
oh [ __ ] right so like when I look the
people go literal with their brands
versus arm Sally Thompson or Rick
Jones I think sure you need to do a
little work but I think what it what I
mean by a little work is your actions
become your brand like if you go read
the early like if you go back to 2009
and go on Twitter people [ __ ] on me for
like but you're the wine guy you can't
start a social media agency I'm like why
I'm like over time my actions will make
me that brand today way more people know
me as an entrepreneur than they do as a
wine guy but the first year of my
existence in the transition I got [ __ ]
on at scale for making that transition
but that's like Marky Mark becoming Mark
Wahlberg like the rock is less of a
wrestler today than he was 10 years ago
right so what I always tell people is
whatever you are now your executions
gonna define you so like to me I'm not
scared of it for that reason and you
didn't get stuck to being the wine guy
you just wrapped everything around wine
at that point I guess garyvee could be
anything at that point I think again
there's so much that goes there's so
many fun Easter stuff is really funny to
me first of all is a terrible name in
the way I spelled it because there's two
silent E's like it's just like a bad
idea for a brand right number two it's
funny how it went down I tried to
register for Twitter four months earlier
than the first time I registered for it
literally I saw it and like I tried to
register for it and the Wi-Fi in London
didn't work and I just like was like
[ __ ] it and I like got back to it four
months later and the first time I had
just Gary and the second time it was
taken I and I never talked about some
like I love how life works in my life I
had never ever tried to register Gary
Vee I don't even know where it came from
I'm no idea why did it end up being
[ __ ] Twitter clerk and smirk and
[ __ ] all the other myspace all the
other [ __ ] you know Friendster but this
was the one that put me on and then that
became me so I didn't think about the
brand name like names to me like when I
watch the entrepreneurs and individuals
think about names too much I laugh
because I'm like what does Facebook mean
what does Nike mean like the
nothing means [ __ ] you like in when it
first starts the execution defines it
McDonald's is an Irish pub right so like
you know like it's the execution and so
that's how I think about branding your
name like if today you're a lawyer
and in four years you want to be a clown
and a nine years later you want to be
the foremost expert in Bourbon it is
your execution and your talent that will
define that over time in the same way
that Justin Timberlake isn't from NSYNC
you know what I mean
like your skills are what predicated the
outcome and I think people get caught up
in like a name which is a quick tale of
like not seeing what actually plays out
when building brand I didn't even choose
my name it just kind of happened and
then I've had to roll with it but I
could choose my mantra what I'm all
about I have the best day ever and I
give everyone high fives and I'm always
positive and like that's what I could
decide and that's really all that
matters like the name just kind of comes
with it shonduras dr. Duras might get
into medical I don't know just whatever
sticks questions hey my name is a Marine
from Charlotte North Carolina my
question is hey we talked for five
minutes before I got food what's up for
me it was that scalability I started
most my first business ventures were
very heavy on me and it wasn't until I
met Holliday that I didn't realize like
it's not just a matter of working harder
and working harder you need to build a
team and we just talked about how to do
that correctly and that was my number
one thing that was hard is because and
you notice earlier I stress like giving
away creative control it's because for
me that was the hardest thing because I
am a creative and I want my videos to
look like this my emails to look like
this and everything else and I'm like
Gary I have the things that my social
media is me I post that but everything
else I need to have a team backing me
and I need to trust in my team I need to
train them to do what I think is right
for the company but in
comes down to it they need to do what
their gut check is and I need to trust
them on that and holidays made so many
decisions that I had no idea was what
was happening and they've all worked out
to be amazing and now we've scaled
multiple businesses side-by-side what
100% he's never stopped and he's made
like three good ideas like 900,000 wrong
calls so my answer is pretty interesting
I think you'll find it fascinating i sat
on the idea of d-roc was like we got a
blog we got a blog Casey's the best and
I was like I'm not gonna [ __ ] I'm too
busy I'm like [ __ ] busy every minute
is like programmed I'm not gonna walk
around with a camera and so when it came
to huh should I have d-roc follow me
around and film it it was no question
one of the biggest challenges for me to
go because don't forget this is now
three plus years ago and the thought of
like now like what's going on but like
it's not super complicated this way
what's so fun about the Internet is
everything is documented people weren't
rolling with somebody else filming them
people were rolling like Roman and like
small cameras right so as far you know
he was just even having the handle was
like felt big yes were small cameras
right that was vlogging and so I'm like
ooh I'm gonna introduce a man following
me and filming me at all times
I knew that 98% and don't forget forget
about being a creator and an influencer
I'm an actual business like c-suite
executives meetings with like 58 year
old conservative like c-suite executives
and like here's d-roc he's filming this
meeting like like that just was super on
except for walking down the street so it
was a really interesting conversation
with myself for about a month of holy
[ __ ] I think I figured it ass out if he
films me I can make unlimited content
I'll have a vlog I'll be able to have
articles I could do a pocket-like it all
came to be pretty quickly of like this
is the gateway to like unlimited being a
media company film everything and the
first place I went is this is gonna be
[ __ ] amazing because my grandkids are
gonna watch this
the next place I went is like
everybody's gonna think I'm a dick face
like it's gonna take me a good year to
like have to eat [ __ ] where everybody
thinks of a douchebag in a narcissist
but I'm completely convinced everyone's
gonna do this that everybody who can't
hold it is gonna have somebody film them
and like literally told d-roc and I put
someone like dude in four years we're
gonna be sitting in meetings where
everybody's gonna have a film person
filming the person could be six people
in a room in a three person meeting and
it's when it happens started happening
eighteen months ago or so we like kind
of got some good chuckles but basically
almost everything I've done in my career
when I was an 18 year old kid and I'm
pushing to launch a website for my dad's
liquor store and we're part of a liquor
co-op and everybody wants us to open a
second store I knew everybody was gonna
[ __ ] um idea of selling wine on the
internet something they didn't even know
existed or was a fad at best so for me
like business decision struggles like
the macro has always been cake I'm an
entrepreneur I don't give a [ __ ] about
what anybody thinks about me I'm good in
life game over in the micro which is far
more secondary which is why I pushed so
many people to not give a [ __ ] because
then everything becomes easy there it's
an everyday thing there's 46 things I'm
struggling with right now chef Lizette
New York City okay so I love the
tactical questions and I really want to
get all of your perspectives literally
from like my life I'm gonna break it
down I have a job super grateful so if
you are building your brand today day
one you have a job a great job you need
to be responsible to that job how many
hours do you have a day to yourself to
yourself so if you have a job before I
can answer for sure I'm gonna need to
know how many hours does your job take
out of your day well it takes 10 the job
takes 10 ok I need to sleep 6
I need seven ok good thanks is great
that's just seven [ __ ] hours there's
a lot of hours I'm excited already keep
going but you know I work seven days so
I give you
ten that you work seven that you sleep
and seven hours in a day that are yours
to do [ __ ] no but I'm saying I go seven
days so we got it you got 49 hours a
week to do damage exactly understand so
what would you guys tactically do to
make more money or where would you
prioritize your time like what would you
if you're talking about building brand
I'm a chef I've been doing it 27 years
so I'm trying to get to the next place
retire as a chef professionally and move
to the next spot right whether it's a
show whether it's you know scaling
myself but is the next spot financial or
is it or is it like something that
you've gotta see its legacy for me it's
legacy I mean you don't invest 27 years
without thinking about what I've already
invested as a chef so it's legacy
dominated so it's not about the short
term money but it is about the money
because how do I eventually retire as a
private chef as a chef period so that I
could focus a hundred percent on
building brand so like tactically I want
to know what would you guys do if you
were me with 27 years these that real
quick yeah you were saying that I just
want to make sure I understand this
question you're saying that you want to
retire because it takes up ten hours so
you're saying you don't want to be a
private chef anymore
correct okay yeah I mean like it's
physically it's just - it's it's enough
I understand right so how how would you
do it I mean it's hard to imagine you
guys being a chef but try to put you're
careful I'm about to cereal yeah like
just put on the chef's hat in every
little dynamic that I gave you what
would you do with that like how would
you take that and go so I actually have
a client that's a chef right and
Instagram he's got four hundred and
fifty thousand followers Facebook 1,000
YouTube 500 Twitter 50 right well you
got 450 on Instagram you knows what
it's on Instagram right he makes it on a
wood kind of like this look this is
rustic Denis the Prescotts his name
right love him he's amazing but he knows
burgers stacked with cheese falling
works until two and a half maybe three
years and for real for real because this
matters to me why did he explode did he
have a viral post did influencers put
him on like shonduras and Tanner Foxx
did he buy ads like what's the punchline
some of his organic and he played the
into the audience that he had which was
a female and so he knew who he needed to
connect with within that world at the
time he had kind of a Facebook group
type situation the apologist Andy for
real the 400,000 of 4.2 million when I
got [ __ ] pissed on that vacation I
got serious how big of a factor was 62nd
Club like first I started posting more
with hashtags I did I immediately go out
and start doing JV with shout outs from
other posts or was it content I mean 60
second Club was insanity when I first
did it like it was just a tactic that I
came up well I'm like seriously real
talk like that was the first thing that
got I remember doing that because that
was December I went on the vacation I
was still in flu I went off the grid to
the island then I was in Florida and
already came up with 60-second Club
because I was really giving a [ __ ] and
that really worked at the time because
the algorithm favored that many comments
in that short of a time right yes it was
just but I think also with even Gary's
right if Gary went down some of my other
clients I work with and he did Orbeez
and pranks you see him coming out of his
glass office like I have clients that
that does five million views for Gary
that doesn't work right you guys don't
care about Hank the [ __ ] out of you get
me some fun right
it's like you have to feed into your
audience I think so he released later
after he had gotten some traction so I
think Dennis's example just the point is
find what fits in your audience right
find what they like and and keep feeding
them less you know
is every fifth fourth post is a burger
Lisette I'm telling you right now cuz
obviously we known each other a long
time
I swear and I've been watching enough to
know I literally think you should flip
[ __ ] I can't be like out of all the
things watching you try to do different
things like when you tried to buy those
printer cartridges when I saw that I was
like yes I'm like this is going to be
her like if she like to me nothing on
earth right now there's the okay take a
hundred people that have talent or
interest and say you're gonna be a
personal brand and make a hundred
thousand a year right hundred people
have interest in to start tracking [ __ ]
can be a chef
could be into wine sneaker music
Authority like whatever you want to be
hundred people go be an influencer that
makes a hundred thousand a year from
branded deals speaking and being that
human right like we do take that same
hundred people and say retail arbitrage
go to [ __ ] t.j.maxx go to thrift
stores go to ready the hundred people
every hundred people one two as an
influencer get to a hundred thousand a
year fifty get to a hundred thousand
year flippin stuff so don't be romantic
about what I sell yourself just sell
period if you want to get if you're
tired and you want to get to the
financial freedom of not having to do
something for ten hours a day well but
no no I mean you know the cost to this
the minute I stop earning money as a
chef and let's say I get to the hundred
K right I've sold my tail off I have the
hundred K that goes really quick if
you're now getting addi wrong but you
know that's this is the part I don't
know I think you're missing the point I
think you just once you make the hundred
K with t.j.maxx thrift stores and garage
sales while you're still chef in your
seven hours a day yeah
posting on [ __ ] Etsy and Craigslist
packing like real life once you do that
you don't quit being a chef and start
trying to build being the chef brand you
go and take those ten hours and make
four hundred thirty thousand a year
flipping stuff so at what point like can
i what is the timeline that i say
I have a 24-month plan to not be a chef
anymore like is that how you work it let
me tell you how I did I mean I think
people are completely utterly [ __ ]
confused on how zero amount of money I
had when I was 34 years old and started
vaynermedia if I had money I wouldn't
have started the company in somebody
else's conference room like like I did
it I had to rely on the hundred thousand
dollar a year salary I had from Wine
Library while it was building Boehner
because this wasn't giving me any money
in the first two years so I had to live
back and forth like when you're
siphoning off of something you know the
time limit is whenever the threshold of
you making enough to get you off the
other thing based on your overhead right
so like do you need 100 you need 47 like
you know like if you're in a
rent-controlled apartment in New York
that person could do it easier than
somebody who isn't there's so many
variables well okay so the wrinkle to
that is I'm a living chef so no that's a
huge I mean I don't pay rent in York
just imagine that that's huge
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's
humongous that's huge so when I need
that on purpose you should that's a
smart move I think I'm gonna say it
again and I'm saying you know I'm
obviously giving you advice because I've
been watching but this is advice for
everybody else the amount of people that
are talented enough to make a hundred
thousand a year being a personal brand
is more than people think and less than
people think and one has to be
self-aware to figure it out
you've been hacking at it for a while I
think it's quicker for you to get to a
hundo by [ __ ] thrifting and flipping
I just do I mean when I tell you that
I'm watching this all go down let me
tell you one place that I think you
could play in I'm unbelievably
fascinated with fashion and jewelry
because my game is nostalgia so I'm
really good at like buying the [ __ ]
teddy bears and the video games and the
stuffed animals but they have a tangible
value right when justin and i look them
up and like oh [ __ ] this South Park
[ __ ] piece of Duty's $27 you look
that up the people that I think have the
biggest advantage in the flip game are
people that have an eye that can go to a
thrift store it doesn't have to say you
know Knicks championship or Opie or polo
it just looks cool and they're like
that's
and I'm gonna like [ __ ] just
merchandise it on Etsy or let go I'm a
caught out whatever in this way or I'm
gonna buy this brooch for twenty [ __ ]
five cents at this garage sale cuz it
looks vintage retro I know how to write
the copy I know how to make it look
fresh and I'm just gonna price it at
$69.99 man I you listen you guys have
all seen it if you're paying attention I
can't get off of these you know they're
people who do it for real
but the people that go in from 0 to 50
or a hundred thousand I can't get it out
of my mind of how real it is
in a world where most Americans don't
make a hundred thousand a year I got a
buddy that in the spring we live in
Maine in the spring he buys Allen Berube
suckle Maine again he buy snow plows and
snowblowers and in the fall he sells
them and he's killing it I'm telling you
it's it's really it means a lot bigger
scale than a thrift but it's if you buy
basketball stuff on ebay in the
offseason and then repost it when the
season starts up again there's a 20 to
40% Delta if you go to stores when they
have sales or close outs or closing you
much how many people could have made a
hundred thousand dollars just by going
to Toys R Us loading up when it was
going out of business and like the utter
ARB I like the thrill hunt
I don't want scalability and flippin cuz
it doesn't get me off I don't want to
buy 5,000 things from China and sell
them on Amazon Marketplace that doesn't
that's not what I want to do right I've
lived that game I sold a billion dollars
worth of wine fine that's buying and
selling I love going and finding [ __ ]
strawberry shortcake for 25 cents for
nine bucks I'm like the [ __ ] greatest
but if I want if I wanted to make real
money there's so much in retail
arbitrage
it's almost uh turley uncomfortable and
if you're a creative person who like
really just loves like buying and
selling t-shirts from thrift stores in
America at scale is just in perpetuity
if you especially if you know how to
write copy and get an eye and really
start learning and then eventually like
I was doing this before you had a phone
and could look up [ __ ]
so I memorized everything I go to garage
something like nine seventeen fourteen
twenty three four seven nine like you
know like me and AJ were joking this
week and I called him because I can
never like theirs
outside of going to James there's
nothing more fun for me and I was like I
always ask him this I'm like bro what
would happen if I just [ __ ] went off
the reservation and retired and just did
this like how would you think I could
make like I was asking that and it was
funny he's like dude I think in a year
or two you'd make millions and I'm like
yeah because really what I would do is
just hop buy a bunch of trucks and just
buy out everybody's garage sale like and
that's like my way the much better way
but by the way I'm trying another better
way right now just out of my own
curiosity I've been buying a bunch of
bulk like magazine type stickers and
different [ __ ] on eBay and just going to
relist them on Amazon Marketplace just
to learn to give people like this has
been such a fun content pillar for me
because it's my hobby but no thing I've
ever done has made more people that
needed more money than this because I'm
not trying to do it like some people who
do it for hundreds of thousands or a
million ten thousand dollars extra a
year for somebody that really needs it
is like insanity and it's sitting there
and the Craigslist free like watching
people you know what's weird about
Craigslist free is you have to be a real
gangster because shit's big like it's
not like buying a bunch of stuff like
you have to be like willing to like get
a truck and pick up a [ __ ] video game
for ten buck free and like but like
people like like you know my whole thing
is like listen I you know this is funny
I never talked about Dover New Jersey I
lived in Dover for a year before we went
to Edison and I never even like I always
wonder why I don't bring it up and like
we went from Queens to Edison's not true
we went for Queens to Dover to Edison
and it's really interesting I've been
asking myself lately like why did I not
why did not happen like why did I just
say that I maybe because a year maybe
was the first time I ever talked I just
said it and then that became the thing
but it was interesting was a really
tough time in my life that year right
like I got picked on the most cuz I
couldn't speak English I remember a very
scary event with my dad with kidney
stones so that always scares me I would
still get freaked but what it was a very
hard time
we didn't have a car like me my mom used
to like sometimes I talk about it walk
three [ __ ] miles to Kmart like like
and what I think about that time or like
how my sister literally my sister when
first came to American Queens everything
she owned came from the garbage my
sisters [ __ ] thing that she sat in as
a baby was a car seat that my cousin
Bobby found in the garbage like we
brought a car seat into our studio
apartment and she sat in it like and the
click and so when desperate times
desperate measures like [ __ ] this
Craigslist eBay free come to my house
take it and repost to like 250 thousand
a year if you're just willing to bleed
and don't give a [ __ ] that you're
walking around town with like TVs and
[ __ ] strollers and [ __ ]
humidifiers and [ __ ] cinder blocks
[ __ ] like you you can get pallets on
Amazon it returns so you can buy a
return pallet of from Amazon and it
comes in some of them don't work and
some of them are okay but some of them
are amazing just open the packaging like
I don't want this and turn it back and
you can obviously spend a lot of time in
us make you want it out of 150 out of
hundred that I can't Fleet a whether
that's right math or not that's my
intuitive answer to that question that's
crazy and what I really like about it is
my biggest thesis is if you love
something you'll win the fact that you
can sell everything allows everybody to
love something like I know waffle makers
make a fuckload of money on the flip I
know in garage sale culture finding
waffle makers right Justin calculators
kill the bottom line is but like
everything kills like everything is
[ __ ] there for the taking
you just have to [ __ ] want it and I
love one every time you got between
about a lot and doing a lot on it people
like yeah but what about the eBay fees
and the shipping I'm like you charge the
customer shipping I think an overlaying
theme here is creativity we talked about
the jewelry boutique that I started my
literal first business I had $400 in the
bank
I didn't know I was gonna start I didn't
think it was gonna be a business it was
just an experiment to learn how to do
stuff online I hit up the companies and
said hey I'm a big-time jewelry guy I'm
gonna be launching a huge boutique can
you send me some of your product so I
can see what the quality is to see if I
learn more my first 100 cells were
necklaces they sent me to check out the
quality and then from there I had made
another $400 and then I started doing
small orders and I didn't do my first
order until two months into the game
with my actual money you got creating
that blows me away is the people that
have the least ability to be fancy are
the ones that are the most fancy beggars
can't be choosers I love doing dirt [ __ ]
you know like I people give me excuses
all the time like like you have no
leverage you want more money you want to
get to the next step you have to like do
whatever and like people like I'm not
[ __ ] waking up at 6 o'clock to go
through somebody's garbage and like cool
send on your [ __ ] couch and complain
on Twitter that this is fake you know
like these are the interactions about
I'm Allah and you don't see a lot of
stuff I'm do young people like your
[ __ ] loser
like you're sitting here saying this is
[ __ ] like here's everybody that's
realistic from Gary does you play like
you say it is true like like like it's
the greatest the person that says no
with no knowledge is the greatest tell
to a losing DNA and so I just think
people are fancy out here like they
write like people are fancy out here
like they're gonna be vc-backed or not
gonna be [ __ ] Casey like go [ __ ]
make $50,000 selling t-shirts it's
literally right here it's in your
[ __ ] face retail arbitrage is
something they will talk about in 50
years because the data is so disgusting
you have to be super basic and you can
make money like you it's important one
more question we're out
hi Ruby a Sutton so my question is more
around back to the conversation of the
transition so you had a toy store you're
doing stuff for your family business and
when you decided to kind of embark on
the personal brand and like what those
first couple of steps were for me the
first couple of steps were you know
don't forget how long ago was it was
acknowledging its existence and so again
we just spent a whole lot of time saying
one out of a hundred versus fifty and a
hundred but like for me knowing a little
bit about you
you're a prime you know where I think
Lisette has to make decisions on like
what's the right move because I want to
get off this thing you have a business
and now it's like layering on top of it
versus I want to get off my business and
maybe you do in the long term but I
think every one of us has different
things like I wanted an identity outside
of something that you know you know I
needed that like now it's easy for me to
talk about at the time like it was
subconscious like I you know like I
knowing what I was doing for my family
business and knowing that the narrative
was gonna be I was put on when I felt
like I was putting on I was like I need
something else to like make this very
clear to the world the [ __ ] is going on
that was my own [ __ ] right we all have
our own [ __ ] I think you for you you
have so many things like personally like
here's the transition you have the Greek
content like that's your set cuz you
have stuff right like you have stuff and
and again the same with Lisette like
others like this is the great I mean
being a minority woman today is like the
great advantage amazing you you do it's
just the truth there's a lot of interest
in it
there's needed for it there's demand for
it it's like more doors are open than
ever that's just [ __ ] facts so you
need to run through them and not say
[ __ ] that was the one window like I was
just telling these guys I'm like I never
talked to see Bruce see Bruce and my
business partner he achieved what I want
you know to dolphin's and then three and
oh those [ __ ] right he's the best
dude ever he liked best like literally
I'm like [ __ ] that's what I'm gonna be
like that's how I see him just the best
I talked to him 3 hours a year I'll talk
to him at all and once in a while when I
talk to him it's just fun it's
not even like mentorship it's just like
I love him I walk out of there every
time right Alex three [ __ ] hours a
year never I never talked to him and I I
every time I walk out I'm like dude dude
78 like and I hope he lives to a
thousand but I always sleeve that I'm
like I'm a [ __ ] idiot one day I'm
gonna be like man I should have spent a
hundred five hundred extra hours with
this incredible man you're gonna do the
same thing this is your golden era right
now it's happening right the [ __ ] now
there's never been a better time to be
you right you've done it and you've got
the optics that the like unlimited
demand you cold email Forbes and fast Co
and everybody they're interested and
guess what it will go away just like
everything else and you'll be like [ __ ]
I had a window from you know late 17 -
you know - 21 and I didn't [ __ ]
squeeze it no different than Facebook
and Instagram ads that I always cry
about you to produce content the
transition is right a [ __ ] LinkedIn
post about what was difficult or how the
government or how you do it or what you
thought or did it knowing that I know
you know one last one so all right my
name is uh max Maxwell from North
Carolina as well so I just keep thanks
max max well if my name was max max well
I'd have at least four million more
followers so I took your advice said
months ago started documenting what I do
I'm in real estate investor kind of
exploded now it's like I'm at the point
where you know real estate stuck for me
you know I'm an entrepreneur by heart
but you know you throw [ __ ] at the wall
and that's what happened worked but I
feel like I'm being boxed in as the guy
that talks about real estate
but max max well we just answered this
one yeah until you start talking about
beard oils or watches or [ __ ] kicks
or wine or [ __ ] the Redskins so how
do I make that so I want to tell me the
content just to start doing it this is
worthless this is where I always talk
about like watch you know I'm always
like I don't know like watch yeah I like
everyone's like you can't do that I'm
like why like in a [ __ ] real estate
episode whatever you want to talk about
next throw it in and watch what happens
people are people like in real life we
like each other for the layers like yeah
we might be homies because we
liked that video game but then later we
find out we both love root beer floats
and riding bikes is like like I don't
understand how people to understand this
like people are so ingrained you know
what it is man this is all about
ideology everybody's in their own
[ __ ] I write this we're all stuck in
our ideology on the real estate dude I
can't like I don't know like make your
next dude I'm out there [ __ ] buying
[ __ ] at garage sales and flipping it do
you know insane that is - people do you
know what kind of weird emails I get for
my friends like yo are you okay like are
you good like you know you're like
ruining like like so I literally just
ran from here I was literally just at
the Google building with Eric Schmidt
and the president of Cuba right that's
where I was just was before right so
that's so like one of the homies that's
in that meetings like literally this
week I was like dude on Monday you're
gonna be at Google headquarters with
Eric Schmidt and the president of Cuba
and today you're out garage selling
that's in the morning buying people's
old trash what are you doing and I text
them back I was like yeah and last night
I was with Sam darn 'old at like at a
super hot spot in New York City and more
people came up to take selfies with me
than him I'm like this is my life
and guess what Mike vacante no Mike my
old trainer if any of you know like he
texted me wallet and he's like yo my mom
just called me she just had to call me
and say her favorite content of yours is
when your garage saleing it's definitely
the place I'm most creative I think a
still shot like I don't do that she said
normally like I'm like trying to be out
there like a [ __ ] real creator I'm
like oh man I [ __ ] missed it it
didn't work out Wow like leaving New
York you look like you know like you
could do it in [ __ ] you want and for the
13 percent that ditch you because
they're like yo I'm here for real estate
max Maxwell don't be talking to me about
sneakers you're gonna pick up twenty
nine percent that are in a net score
you're gonna win because the biggest
advantage we have is I'm real estate
dude I love [ __ ] snow globes I like
love the Raiders I eat pizza like my
brothers
that's like the advantages we have are
the layers and everybody's trying to
sell vanilla when everybody wants to buy
chocolate I'm selling cuz I'm chocolate
not just like I'm one thing we're
missing the layers everybody's trying to
vanilla themselves into like I'm the
cryptocurrency gal and you're an awesome
sister and you're great at skiing and
you have thoughts about you know Tiger
Woods coming back and you love like
you're a foremost expert on [ __ ]
peanut butter and jelly you see what I
mean
go ahead I think that a lot of people
are watching you because they dig max
Maxwell so you need to tell the people
your story why are you moving to the
next thing and why should they come and
why is it gonna be interesting I think
if you build this rapport with your
audience over the next couple days weeks
and then transition them to something
else they're gonna come because they
love you not just real estate and
there's maybe people that are watching
you for real estate but then they they
learn what a baller you are and you're
doing X Y or Z over here they want to
learn more about it and they get
motivated and then that audience comes
and then you become friends with them
and then you move on the next thing I
went from jewelry boutique to snapchat
to YouTube to eSports to like those
things aren't cannot most of your
contents dad's yeah look at your now
selling on the shot actually other
things but there is no dad Gary cuz
that's a thing we decided to go the
other way so it's not everything it's
you got to be you right like like I went
completely private on the family part
like everyone's doing their own thing
but that's your strengths and unique
nough sand - Shaun Doris's point he's
probably right about like build it up
and convert I'm just like [ __ ] them just
make a barber video out of nowhere and
they're like what the [ __ ] am I on the
right channel is that max - what the
[ __ ] like it all can work like syrup
like it just can all work and I think
people are overthinking it and they
self-identified but I think we're going
to vanilla and I'm trying to push
creators and bloggers and individuals
and businesses to like show all the
layers because there's a lot of there's
people that literally bought my sneakers
because I'm a Jets fan like literally
that is the single reason not I made
content for them not that they associate
entrepreneurship but like we're a small
little community and we're mad at
everybody and like he's of Jets fan so
[ __ ] it I need a new pair of sneakers
like you you've got to
give people more reasons not less like
and you weren't even that guy ten months
ago so again we're over thinking like
and we're you know by the way let me
give you some real good news nobody
gives a [ __ ] you know why everything
works for me nobody gives a [ __ ] like
you know what it's like we get way too
serious on ourselves if I tomorrow start
being the playdough dude like at the end
of the day everyone who's sad here like
[ __ ] I really loved when he did business
[ __ ] content like I'm not about this
Plato life like I promise you this when
I go fully into Plato and 24/7 there's
no business for you and you're like [ __ ]
that sucked because we loved it like
you'll all leave and do your thing I
promise you a month later you'll forget
I like you like me because it was good
for you go back and watch your favorite
episode or piece of content but like
it's gonna be okay like and and I really
started realizing that when iconic
people were dying in the last five years
I watch and I'm like [ __ ] and I say this
often if Prince only gets a day and a
half then like nobody gives a [ __ ] max
max well you know what I mean like if
Prince only gets a day and a half before
everybody moves on and nobody gives a
[ __ ]
well then we better get real serious
about what the [ __ ] are we really and
realize I ate every day knowing nobody
gives a [ __ ] and so thus it makes me
very easy to do my thing and like let
the chips fall and I think that kind of
level of humility to go along with the
confidence to do whatever the [ __ ] you
want that contradiction that's where all
the [ __ ] magic is like who like like
you can't make that transition coz what
somebody's gonna leave a comment be like
oh I [ __ ] came here I subscribe for
that real estate stuff like you know
like they do that to me all the time
and I'm like cool like there's nine
trillion more of that coming and there's
9 million in the back and like there's
other people who can feed you like today
it's about [ __ ] buying Barbies and
flipping it you got it cool thank you so
much everybody here I'm looking forward
to jamming with you now in a few minutes
everybody watching thank you for
listening or watching the askgaryvee
show no even question of the day we're
just wrapping up this one totally
different tune thank you so much for
Norris Holliday thank you so much see ya
[Applause]
[Music]